okay hi everyone by the way somebody is
clicking there um
all right this is our third live stream
design review of the day
we are looking right now at flight data
and
um
where have we got to the last time we
were reviewing this
i think we looked at most things but
you had a couple suggestions they should
be all implemented as much as they are
implementable
why did this um pink out
not sure that it was working
earlier okay so it's probably a data set
that didn't get saved in the notebook by
default and i don't know whether a data
set that is output from one of these
things
um
you know this spacing is just really
yucky
there why is there that giant space
there
yeah it should be a little bit smaller i
mentioned this
okay flight path okay
this in the data set right this should
surely be iconized in some way
otherwise that's definitely going to
make a mess of the data set but this
should be
done by dataset
presumably
because otherwise it would be very hard
to prepare this
yeah okay fair enough
fair enough
how do i copy that
okay so if i copy data clipboard to
plain
oh very nice
should that red line be thicker
i would think so
okay
okay so now
all right
so let's say i want to find flights
the most recent okay let's say flight
data
now i want to find the most recent
flights out of um
let's see what is it called
ah i got misspelled it well it managed
to get it anyway okay there we go so
that's the airport
and if i just give that as an entity
inside flight data will it understand
that
yes it'll get the flights going in and
out of that airport
how many flights is it going to get
well the ones for the current data day
that they have
it's also going to get the flight data
for it so all of the various properties
is that the best thing to do it by
default for a whole day i mean for a big
airport this is a tiny little
you know tiny
mostly general aviation airport
right
if i did this for lax for example it's
going to crash
right um
i don't think we've seen any crash it
will take a while i have done it for lax
it works fine yeah i have done it with a
semicolon can we do it for an hour or
something instead of for a day
i mean this is a very dinky airport and
look at how long it's taking why is it
taking so long
what the heck is it doing what is it
doing
it's gathering the data for all of the
flights
no no no that's not a good answer it
says computing flight data
what does that
mean well it's taking all that data and
then computing the
flight map
also also there's a minor point but
somebody else who's
noted the fact that this is giving like
six decimal places of accuracy for this
percentage is absurd
is anybody here to note that or not
nope i can't i can't
pause to report that yep
what is it doing this is crazy why is it
so slow
i predict there are less than 30 flights
here
why is it so slow come on there's
something else going on
now maybe
rendering them all and there's something
wrong this is not useful
okay it's way too slow
okay what is it doing what is going on
now it must handle all the things that
you've got
but but
what is it giving by default why is it
not just giving i don't understand why
isn't it giving by default just the
flights
what is it going to give by default
it's going to give an association of all
the flights with all their properties
okay that's the wrong thing to give
because as we can see it's way way way
way way too slow
and so the default here should just be
to give the flights
okay this is just wrong
okay
okay so the flight of the of the same
day or just the next flight
no
look i think we can get it for a whole
day we should do it for a whole day
if we cannot do it for a whole day we
should do it for an hour
okay but you decide which of those is
going to be i think day is most useful
okay fine what is it doing what is it
doing now it's entering something like
this
it's it's crazy
yeah but it's with any big
output nothing special here to flight
data
but
i know but but signing up for something
which is pretty much guaranteed to hang
like this is just a real mistake
okay why did that take so long it's got
mostly iconized things i'm not believing
you i'm not believing this
i don't know i mean stephen like
since we introduced summary boxes for
polygons even the simplest graphics
takes a minute to render
their off or pretty goods
well i am sorry what are you saying
look there's a lot of complicated stuff
that needs formatting now even polygons
need a long time to render
no but i don't understand this this
that okay so this needs to be looked at
by other people then if this is because
this is iconized it didn't have to
format anything in here no it did format
and came to the conclusion it's too big
size and memory 50 megabytes
i was going to guess 50 flights so i
wasn't too far off
so if i say
like percent to sub
30 or something
okay so we've got the
previous flights
i don't understand is that every
previous fight of that tail number
um
in the last day or so
well no no what is it it says previous
flights
what does it mean
it seems selected last week
okay we got to get our act together here
okay if it says previous flights
i mean
again we could have taken it since the
beginning of time since the plane was
manufactured
you know what i'm saying
but that's not what we mean right
is that correct i mean
it's some arbitrary time a week a month
a year
do we know
okay
where is
oh i see that was the key that was right
okay
okay
flight path so
you have a specification of a path
how is that being done
no no we don't have a specification of a
path we just have a geo position
so how do we know at what time it was at
each geo position
we have time for each each position
in the geo position is a time correct
yes for flight path yes
so each of so inside the geo position
there's
longitude latitude elevation time
okay but that's how you're recording the
time but didn't we have some other plan
to have a geopath that has time as okay
but that has not been implemented is
that correct
this function does not exist yet
okay what is it what is our rough plan
for how that will work
it's like a time series right so it's
got interpolation data and things like
that correct
yes
yes it's a little bit complicated
because
we had some discussion because we need
we need some convenient coordinate
system we also want to attach probably
some properties like speed or other
things to it it must be in a convenient
coordinate system
right
but so
is roger here
he's going to join us i think
john
okay but well this is related to time
series right because
because in the end this geopath you
should be able to ask the question given
the geopath
when was the plane at this coordinate
do you see what i'm saying maybe even
involves the play nearest to this
coordinates right fine or where was the
plane at exactly noon
yeah
right even if that wasn't a sample time
yeah which is the same thing as with
time series being able to sample a value
at a precise time
right yeah
um
because this this function
this graphics tour video thing
has sort of the same set of issues
although they're a little bit more
uh walled in
because what that is
is
a
video
exploring a graphic
2d or 3d
with a certain
you know it's it's similar to a point on
the earth at a certain height in the
sense that you are looking at a point in
the graphic
with a certain
uh zoom level so to speak
does that make sense
michael you understand what we're saying
not really i don't know what this is
this project you're talking about
okay so what this is
which i'm trying to get some degree of
this is
graphics currently it's called graphics
talk video shady did we have a different
name that we were considering for this
no this is the original one we proposed
and nothing no no alternatives
okay so this is the idea is you have a
picture and this is wandering around the
picture with various zoom levels showing
you kind of your tour of the picture
michael surplus i see
okay and i thought that is a similar
type of problem particularly when people
are talking about bezier curves and who
knows what else
to the problem of geopaths
does that make sense
yes to me
similarly on geographics but that's not
related to this discussion
geopositions like driving directions and
so forth
right and i mean the fact is exactly but
but there's another point here which is
the example you've given right there
would be a geographic and the
coordinates should be geo coordinates
yeah that that i think should be
eventually supported geographics will be
supported but not a dynamic geographics
i yeah maybe something like geographics
the world with actual geographics
positions would make sense
with these video generators we're going
to have to iterate that several times
because in principle i think that sort
of a 2d camera
is a it's a higher dimensional thing
it's not only
sort of this is like the minimal spec of
what you want to achieve but the camera
has an orientation it has a zoom level
and in 3d the camera again it's not only
position it has also an orientation yeah
and focal length and all kinds of stuff
exactly it has more things and so you
know like in 3d a lot of these moves are
broken down and have names like in
cinematography there's a tumble and a
roll and you know a push-in and a
push-out and then things like that
yeah
uh
but but nevertheless my sort of
synthesizes a full basically like a full
robot path if you like
right but the reason
yeah so this is a combination of time
series
this is essentially
why isn't this geo positions within time
series
or or positions within time series
why isn't this thing why isn't the outer
rapper a time series basically
no for both
flight path and it seems a little wrong
i mean i think that first
i mean that means that the most
important thing you think is time
and i don't think so i think it's sort
of what you look at
you know
i think you know
if then we should generalize your
trajectory to trajectory because
trajectories are such common things in
in the real world in physics everywhere
well that wouldn't be a bad idea perhaps
but then
then i mean trajectories are space-time
things
exactly maybe there's some additional
information attached
they've also got velocities exactly
yeah and they've got perhaps
for a for a flying turtle they've got
orientations of various kinds in space
well
okay
by the way trajectory but i think that
you know i mean bottom line is that one
has to actually use these a little bit
to get familiar with if we can't play
with them i don't think one can make a
lot of statements
i agree another name for this might be
trajectory video
which i kind of like actually
judy
no objections i was thinking
is that more of a 3d
name or no might work for 2d as well
and then
when we have directory 3d video
yeah no no we don't need trajectory 3d
but
it knows whether it's the spec is
totally different what's that the spec
is totally different
i think you generalizing too early i
think that's you know premature you know
generalization don't work so good
well i just don't think graphics tour is
going to make it as a name
okay
i don't think this function is going to
make it beyond a very basic experimental
level if at all into 13.00 that's what i
think too
um
because they need to be finished and
they need to be explored and tested or
they won't be any good
so
yeah so
maybe something a subterranean
experimental thing but not more than
that probably
uh okay so so just coming back to flight
data
and um just to to so what we're doing
right now for flight path
is just you what is this this is a
composite geo position
with time stamps in the geo position
correct that seems weird
doesn't it seem weird
i mean why i mean why why do we have it
if it's real
we have geoposition has a time
management right
i mean this is that's like
elevation time
yeah
yeah no i know we need it for astronomy
but like yeah yeah look eventually we
need time series here roger
this is one of the applications of time
series but we don't have that right now
and we want to be able to
you know have flight information
um
okay what else did we need to look at
with respect to flight data
um
this is
women
i see that's the property and that's the
time right yeah
which is the same as weather data
correct
yes
is it the same argument order
yes
i see it's air temperature data for
example would just have
the time second argument but otherwise
it's it's weather data blah blah blah
comma air temperature comma yesterday is
that correct
yes and i think some of them are even
smart enough to figure out what the
argument happens
awareness is this so this is like live
data like it's really yesterday
yes
where where is that data i mean where
did it work we've had it in wolfen alpha
for a decade it comes from the faa
originally i see
okay
all right what else do we need to figure
out about other than this horror of
returning just way too much stuff here
um i mean it's just a question what the
default for flight data
of a given flight
so if you if you have flight data so zoe
the default given flight is clear that
the 4 4 airport was not clear
what is the default for a given flight
the association of everything
all right
cylinder comments that he has a fun
example for graphics to a video
okay
like to hear about it
um
okay what else do we have to figure out
here so this is so for example let me
see for this flight
i want to
uh
look at its um show me its height as a
function of time
the sub-values don't broke all yet
you have to go to flight right all right
now
okay by the way this autocomplete is
crazy wrong
right
just
pointing that out
right
can you make it can you pass that on
yeah
okay so now what is it elevation
uh altitude
there's no auto complete here that's
wrong right
do you understand that
why is this taking so long
okay wait a minute okay so i want to see
the historical altitude values for this
flight
now you can call you can add a time of
all and we'll grab everything
magnificent what does the x get what is
the y scale is it unit does it have
units
uh
it should it's feet
how does it know that
it's in the temptees
and it's pulling it from
your default uh unit system
oh cool there we go
that's pretty cool hey roger don't you
think that's pretty cool that's very
cool
nice
so well but you have now you have a
flight from uh from sea level to sea
level i mean if you go from denver to
new york we start higher right yeah
to be make sure that
so this is the ag no this is not agl can
you get agl from this
you have to do it yourself
because we would have to look up the
elevation as well well we have the
elevation data
yes but it's a little bit time consuming
to do it
but if you ask for the agl shouldn't you
be able to get the agl without having to
do it yourself
for those of us who are not flight data
geeks um absolutely ground level
okay okay yeah
well then we should probably consider
what we consider what our our default
uh value is for flight
because it may be that somebody doesn't
want to wait for that absolutely they
shouldn't wait for that i don't think
you should return
a ton of stuff for a single flight i
really don't but even for senior flight
well how long is it going to take
i would go you know
a rival departure
i don't know
i mean if it's reasonably fast it's okay
but i just let me try i mean
okay let's try this
this
random
we're waiting we're waiting we're
waiting this is really slow
okay i wonder what most of that time is
being spent on can we find that out do
you really need all that i mean isn't
there like a property that tells you
everything
sorry yes
for example the future flights and
previous flights and so on i mean i
asked about a particular flight
i mean it's amusing to see all the stuff
why don't you find out what takes the
time you get what i'm saying
yes
like our future and previous taking a
lot of time
i think so
and it's the flight map i don't think
you need that
i mean if you have the path you can work
out that stuff and i mean
it's nice that you can get flight map
but i don't think you have to
pre-compute all that stuff
am i making sense
um
okay then we return a smaller set by d4
if you don't specify exactly all or
something i think so yeah i think that's
right
um
the other thing you were asking about
last time was the flight number the
right number is not always not the right
number the tier number
wasn't always provided by the data i'm
sorry what
the detail number of the plane which
is that right which which is flag
and and uh we looked into this where is
the tail number there isn't the tell
number yeah yeah it's not always
provided so that's that's not an issue
this one has a tail number because it's
a general aviation flight
right
um
why does it have aircraft type missing
that's very odd
that's extremely odd
yeah that property is
a little spotty
and that's i think it's something that's
probably probably should be could be
retrieved from an faa
api
because that object
xoj 539
i mean i'm sure i could look up
well that's not done
when will this knows what type of plane
it is
yeah there well that knows it's that
knows the plane type
but but there's an faa
thing
that gives that
i
mean that's where where he's getting it
from
does that make sense
do we have an faa service connection
we don't probably right now
but given given what we're doing with
flight data we might consider trying to
get that
um
the other thing you tried last time was
that you looked up all the flights which
going from uh flying from one plane one
day from los angeles to new york or so
if you had seen some uh
planes which stopped somewhere in the
air would seem to be stopping the air
and
[Music]
some flights have spotty data they cut
out in fact the example right i just
went past it um
showed the showed that
uh we've gone and improved the results
because we know the end points obviously
and so at least you know the beginning
and end and what we have of in between
most of them are pretty full but some of
them
like this one are missing the beginning
and parts of their flight path
that's freaking weird
this is just totally weird
maybe that's maybe they uh
is it conceivable that a big plane like
that can be using vfr
i guess i don't know why i didn't think
they did that for a big
you know commercial passenger planes
and not are not no but it doesn't make
any sense because it's from radar data
isn't it
i think that will be worth checking into
why that's happening
maybe there's some issue with our feed
maybe there's something set wrong for
that this doesn't seem right to me
yeah i'll look into some of that i mean
look at look at some other services that
try and give faa data so they can see
something better for this flight
make sense
so for example let's see if i go
well let's try this then
so now this should be the flights
yesterday and then we're going to get
okay there are the flights
and now
for each of these we say entity value
can we say that entity value of flight
path
yes i think that should
okay notice the bug here please report
it
okay
make sense
oh come on i'll see if i can get that
working
no no but
no i didn't think it would work actually
okay so i say flight data flight path is
that correct
okay so now i say
geo
what am i going to say i'd say
geographics of laws
what's that
of geopoles
all the geo positions
why is this taking so hard there
okay that is a cool picture
that is a geodesic bundle
okay so now those dotted lines so what
did you do here clearly they can't be
geodesics then they would be they can't
all be gt6 then i know that that's the
joke
but they are roger with respect to some
bizarre metric when there's the wind
included yeah i mean it's doing optimal
control for this stuff yeah i don't even
know what that what the description of
the of the of the space is when there's
wind included in the in the in the gdc
what the heck would that be what is the
mathematical description of that but
it's also actually efficiency because
the the
the jet engines are differently
efficient at different temperatures
ah
and at one point it took crew time into
a point to account to i don't think they
do that anymore but
what what are the dotted lines said guys
there's the things that we try to fill
in data
just to answer the question geopath
when it sees that
it has a gap in the data
it then draws it as a dotted line is
that right
are these geoparts incomplete how does
it know that they're incomplete
michael do you know that i do not know
right now why they'll do that
no no not not why they're incomplete but
why they're dotted yeah i say i don't
know why they outdoored it
okay
yeah i would have expected a full
line well i mean it's good that they're
dotted
let's be happy that they're dotted but
the you know why are they dotted i mean
so here
if i say normal of this
what the heck
how do i get the points out of that
okay
so
is the time no what why did it get to be
dotted
that's the question
oh no i don't know okay i mean it's
great
but but let's figure it out yeah
um
okay
well
if i it's a pity that map is so fuzzy
behind it that how do i get to it well i
can get it to be a vector map somehow
and
right anything else particularly to see
here what about the heights what what
would happen if i wanted to show these
heights
in which form do you want to show them
well i want to show a bunch of lines so
i would have to get them out of the
geopolis how do i get the elevation out
of the geo positions
you would probably have to extract
all come
four comma three list four comma three
isn't there a way to get an elevation
out by just saying elevation
does that work with multi points
yes
so what i want to say but now you miss
the corresponding time because they're
not equidistant
i see so what i have to do is i have to
say time common elevation or something
what is the appropriate time
well anyway this is going to make a nice
example
and you can actually do it
i will just go but
what was it called
nope
oh for goodness sake
well micro mass mass
well anyway let's let's do this we can
say
there
wait a minute what
oh
so if i now say just as an approximation
if i now just say list line plot
yeah
we have an example this
yeah the problem is the sampling
yep
just for fun i'm curious histogram
of flatten
percent 24.
that's pretty very amusing
okay
oh look at that that is so cool
those are
those should be flight levels going east
and west no they're going that was going
one way right that probably means that
they have traffic lanes so they're
no no no elevations that are not
roger is that is that the flight level
even numbered flight levels go east west
an odd number go
west east or or the other way around i
don't remember which but so this picture
basically shows that because we asked
from la to new york they're missing all
the flight levels that are intermediate
levels right that's what i'm saying like
traffic lanes there's certain elevations
that are not used
right
um
i see is commenting that one can get
yes we are well aware of the fact you
can get these uh
uh flight trackers for all these
different kinds of things the the
problem is the aggregation of that data
that is more challenging this is a nice
picture you should show this picture yes
in the examples it's really a nice thing
all right i gotta go good stuff um
great this looks like it's ready to roll
and um
very nice maybe make the changes
thank you
sounds good all right see you guys later
bye thanks folks on live stream too